[Musique]
1943 il y à 75 ans dans ce champ du
mexique
ce n'est pas du maïs qui sort de terre
mais un volcan le pari poutine est le
tout premier est encore aujourd'hui un
des rares que les scientifiques ont vu
naître grandir et mourir
[Musique]
tout débute le 20 février à 300 km de
mexico vers 16h les pulido remarque une
crevasse dans leurs champs il s'en
échappe une odeur de soufre
puis la nuit de puissants jets de gaz
sème la panique
l'éruption commence le pari comptines et
b
l'air se remplie de poussière des
milliers d'animaux su qu'on les
villageois malheureusement auront le
temps de fuir
[Musique]
volcanologues eux prennent le chemin
inverse et s'installe sur les flancs du
volcan
il note sa température étudie ces gaz et
trace sa silhouette sa courbe de
croissance est spectaculaire
dès le premier jour il s'élève à 50
mètres en une semaine à 130 et après un
an il frôle les 400 ce sera à quelques
mètres près sa taille adulte
le pari coutume ne se calme pas pour
autant les chercheurs remarquent même
des cycles parmi ces explosions sa lave
change aussi de compositions à mesure
qu'ils vieillissent et certaines clés
avance d'un demi kilomètre par jour deux
villages seront tour à tour abandonnée
puis enseveli
ce qui n'empêchera pas par nous et de
l'utiliser comme décor
[Musique]
le volcan finira par s'apaiser et en
1952 après un dernier soubresaut
il s'endort probablement pour toujours
c'est en tout cas le parcours typique
des volcans de cette famille le pari
comptines et du type cône volcanique la
forme la plus simple avec une seule
cheminées ses éruptions sont moins
violente que les volcans comme le monde
s'installe à nice qui ont une structure
complexe et à magna et paix l'autre
grande famille inclut les volcans
d'hawaï avec leur lave fluide qui se
répand sur de grandes surfaces
même éteint le pari goutines reste
aujourd'hui un laboratoire à ciel ouvert
que ce soit pour observer l'érosion ou
le retour de la visitation
et au milieu de cet océan de l'affiché
un clocher d'église derniers vestiges
d'un village un écho lointain à la
célèbre poupée
[Musique]